foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
you guys love we are back Ryan how we
feeling how we feeling on this Thursday
man pretty good we lost uh we lost a
member of our crew to baseball today so
that's you know we gotta we've got to
carry the vibes
gotta carry The Vibes carry the energy
and carry the winners that's that's what
we're gonna do right I mean we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna win we're gonna
win Good Vibes only uh my name is Greg
welcome to the show at first off welcome
to the show my name is Greg to your left
is producer Ryan we are on the coldest
streak in the history of betting
so my man bowling had to sit this one
out to get warm
but there are some big games there are
actually two games two big games tonight
going on on TNT uh with two current
number one seats trying to keep their
place in the standings drop your Best
Bets for tonight's Prime Time games in
the chat we're talking Celtics bucks
Pelican nuggets uh Pelicans versus the
Nuggets I said Pelican nuggets ah you
guys got what I meant but Ryan what are
the people talking about people aren't
talking yet but I'm I would like to talk
to the people for a second because if we
hit this parlay today with just the two
of us and obviously you know the regular
OG gang in the chat darien85 saying yo
that's my guy uh if we win today
I can make a guarantee that I will never
let Michael bowling hear the end of it
and for me that's huge that's like my
business if we can if we could do that
that that is better than anything I have
ever gotten as a gift in my life so
let's lock in let's Center ourselves uh
Maximo uh chingon says y'all gotta stop
sucking I agree uh somebody left a
comment on one of our tick tocks last
week that called us the sports books uh
number one uh donators
mean but it made me laugh very hard I
won't lie I screenshotted it uh probably
we'll use it soon
um so all right uh shall
we start shall we we shall I think we
shall are are we getting anything in the
comments
uh like following us donators in the
comments or anything like of those sorts
or locks uh we've got no uh well bath
half boy said what's up Greg in the rat
uh you know a little disrespectful to
start but all good you know uh B
Thompson wants to know if Joker's just
playing you know
so I I I'm not an NBA Insider Greg like
if I like I'm on FanDuel right now I
could try and find the Scoops but uh Jay
swerve says Jason Tatum 30 plus points
I think the Celtics Bucks game because
it's the earlier one is probably a good
place to start
um I'm also seeing nuggets first quarter
money line from Disney bands
uh Trey Murphy two plus threes from B
Thompson
Tatum over four and a half threes from
Jay swerve okay so James were Jay swerve
is heavily on Jason tatums from what I'm
understanding
um
uh what do we let's I'm gonna make a
decision and we're gonna go to the
Celtics game yeah yeah I mean while you
make your decision I'll read off some
comments because Jalen Brown 25 points
nah I think today's the I think tonight
tonight's a Tatum night because it kind
of has to be for the Celtics like it's
kind of one of those things where this
is the biggest game of the Celtics
season by a long shot it's the last
matchup you have with the Bucks and like
pretty much a last prayer I think
somebody's got to go off and it's gonna
be Jason Tatum all right I I trust you
only reason I trust you in this spot is
because you are a Celtics fan so you
would know your team very very well and
then this spot against Milwaukee a man
is rocking with Jason Tatum or what are
we doing Ryan are we going over 30 you
know I think 30 plus I think we get we
start out a little plus 105. I I'm okay
with making this a little okay e Ramirez
saying Drew holiday first shot I mean I
was gonna get into my Spiel and then I
see that like I should literally I just
said we're trying to win we're doing
first Baskets at a parlay
hey hey don't let him throw you off your
Vibe get into go go what were you about
to say no no I'm just saying I think I I
do think that like I think this is going
to be a star type of night in this game
at least I know that's not really a hot
take and you know that might be chalky
to some in the chat but like that we we
this needs to be a Jason Tatum like I am
here type of game and I think it will be
do I think the Celtics win I I don't
know and I doubt that we're gonna pick a
side in this game but I think you can
pretty much count on some shots being
put up from Tatum's end and they kind of
have to go in tonight that's just like
that's how I feel
um if somebody wants to say something on
the Bucks though I'm 100 like the Bucks
I've been playing the best basketball in
the NBA for the better part of three
months now so well our boy B Thompson is
in the comments talking about Giannis he
says Giannis 12 boards I also saw
somebody Blaze one three two one says
Giannis over 17 and a half rebounds and
assists so the comments
they're tending towards Giannis and uh
bagel and lock said he loves your play
30 for Tatum with a plus sign next to it
free money I like that
I I mean those are you know Bagel
unlocks is bringing Good Vibes today uh
he knows I need it but I think
I I liked I like the Giannis rebounds
play I do the only guy down there for
the Celtics is really uh Al Horford you
know Rob Williams is still dealing with
the knee so I do I like over 12 and a
half that seems a lot to me we already
have a plus money play I feel like we
could probably tease it down to 10 and
420 isn't a terrible number for me I
think he gets this pretty easily I think
so too I like it I like it all right I I
think that that's a lock like 10
rebounds I think that's a lot minus 420
got me feeling kind of ooh but um
we already got A plus money in there so
we can we can we can juice it up a
little bit of a bagel bagel and lock say
how can we forget about next Legend Luke
Cornett rebound Luke Garnett is not it's
not boxing out be honest that's just not
happening if that if that happens uh
hell will also freeze over tonight so
that's you know that won't happen I I
don't think
um I okay this guy dizzy bands
um shout out to you for constantly
putting the alarm emojis around your
text but uh it keeps saying nuggets
first quarter money line and if nuggets
first quarter money line hits tonight
and we don't bet it I you know I I might
go I might go crazy so but do we just do
that because
he's well I don't want to encourage I
don't want to encourage what I think
he's doing
um my thing is if we if we had a take on
jokic then I would be all in
you know going to Denver planning that
altitude first quarter I'll be in favor
of it but
I don't know Ryan
did you did you put it in there
oh no we just got two beds in it no I
saw I saw the odds move and I thought
that you uh I thought that you inserted
it in
no
um
all right I
I would like to well why did it it
didn't move oh 305 305 okay cool all
right oh they're they're Darien Darien
DeAndre or Dion I hope I didn't butcher
that uh they said come on guys don't be
scary so
okay
I don't know I mean I don't necessarily
know what that means because it's scary
I think that was a misuse of the word
scary to be quite honest with you
um and then dare dare and Dion said uh
Joker is doubtful I believe he was
upgraded I yeah
I also saw some Trey Murphy uh threes
over two and a half threes I the jokic
being uh with the whole injury business
is
I I love them I just like I don't want
it to be one of those nights where he's
walking around the court and I'm like
why did we bet overs for yogish
yo I'm over here laughing because B
Thompson 1992 says uh
let me check my sources on yogic so go
check your sources come back to us with
sourced information so we can figure out
about this bet that we're about to place
uh Ryan can we put a pin in this one and
and talk about Drew holiday because I
promise you this is like the fifth
comment that I've seen talking about
Drew holiday's point total uh I saw 15
plus here I see 18 plus uh
what's your thoughts
I mean he's just coming off a 50 piece I
believe so I think
it it's boy total being at 17 and a half
is weird to me I'm not necessarily
saying that we should take that over but
um
Maybe
maybe 15 plus
I like it
what do you think
four is that four legs for oh oh yeah
now we're we're sitting good right four
links Plus 457.
I yeah
it almost makes me think that we can do
I don't know why I feel like we need to
protect ourselves but let's just say in
the event of
we're at so we're at four legs at plus
390 if we do over twelve and a half
okay I I don't hate it and then we add
we just add one more leg oh we're at
plus 406. how about that there it is
there it is that's even better
yeah
so
I don't know uh Alex
2r14 Brook Lopez blocks I saw that I saw
that hey okay he's dropping it a lot now
now it's
I don't want to go too heavy on this
game there's supposed to be four legs on
this game
uh four legs on this first game but you
know what that means that means like if
we cook it up in this first game
we're feet chilling feet kicked up for
that second game that's true I would
like to know from Alex is he talking
about one block or two blocks because
there's a stark difference uh according
to FanDuel on what that would do for us
there is
there is that's a huge jump right there
between one and two
I could see Jalen Brown just going head
down to the basket and getting blocked a
few times do I think it's by Brook Lopez
every single time if I knew that I I
would bet a lot of money on it but I
don't know for sure uh what about uh
my man Brandon Ingram I I this is like
my second or third time see we got
Carter bass and Ingram points we also
got Big Gerald saying Brandon Ingram
plus I mean 20 plus
um
what do you think I I what I would say
is is I've seen this last couple of
games he has been assertive on the
offensive end but
what's the numbers what's the numbers 20
I think he can go get 20.
I think he could yeah I mean
I think he could do 20. bath F boys
spelling out Jalen like the obnoxiously
spelling out Jalen Brown vertically one
plus steel uh you know I
all of a sudden all of a sudden we're
starting to bet player defense I don't
understand why we're doing that
um he's at 26. 20 plus is pretty easy
based on what we have uh now that I said
it's easy he's gonna you know score five
but
um
yeah I mean okay if we were to do that
say the Nuggets we have the Nuggets
winning the first quarter Brandon Ingram
20 plus points Jason Tatum 30 plus
Giannis 10 plus Drew holiday over 12 and
a half points
I
I don't really see I don't see an issue
I mean you know what I'm about to
advocate for
more juice no actually
no actually less juice I I think we can
we I think we can play around with
something in this early game to help get
us there I think Eileen on teasing down
giannis's rebounds maybe just the hair
uh I feel like let we can let's take a
look at it it might take us underneath
that five
plus 500 mark
I don't mind it going under plus 500
usually we're trying to keep it around
Plus 400.
um what since when
you got to know that I do I do these
shows with you
and I've been here since the beginning
and if if it hasn't been plus 500 Ryan
has not been with it
okay Greg I'm gonna well should we ask
the chat what we usually do because the
chat I know I know some of our some of
our brothers in the chat are always what
we're trying to get it to
ask him
Chad I could have I could have at least
let Gregory know what the magic number
usually is for us
yeah you guys let us know
I can guarantee you I know what it is
well I mean
guarantee me how I dude it's it's always
been plus 400. it's never not been plus
400. oh five legs plus 400 you Brian you
were like
parlay if we're not in plus 500
territory
start our season
that doesn't mean that's where I've
ended up I don't hate this
I
I it's unbelievable I don't I don't hate
this I I think if this guy DJ bans
whatever his name is comes in here and
the Nuggets don't wear in the first
quarter I DJ bands might be getting a DM
from me but because there's no other
reason why I would have the Nuggets win
in the first quarter other than the fact
that he dropped it a million times uh
Brandon Ingram 20 plus points everyone
seems to agree might score 30 tonight so
I feel like that's that's okay Jason
Tatum 30 plus Drew holiday over 12 and a
half and Giannis eight plus rebounds
I like it I don't see how this doesn't
hit
Plus 426.
I like it I mean we can hold on hold on
hold on now now you've got me now I'm
doing math
and that's bad news for everybody
okay if we do that
and then we take away what are you doing
Ryan you got to talk us through you got
to talk right all right I'm adjusting
giannis's rebounds to over I think what
did I do over eight and a half
and then I'm trying to get Drew holiday
at
10 no that's not really what we want is
it
huh yeah plus 39. I did this to myself
though there was no reason for me to
have done that
I don't know why
I I I kind of don't know why you did
that either but it does look locky it
does I'm I'm trying to bring Good Vibes
to it it did look lucky
okay I like that yeah overall I'll take
over 11 and a half
so we've got our we've got our guys
bagel oh okay sorry go ahead go ahead no
guys bagel and locks was saying I
dropped Ingram or Tatum before dropping
Giannis boards
um I know I saw him suggest the the 28
and a half line
um
can we hey hey we're getting we're
getting we're getting
we're getting comments in the chat
that are referring to US changing the
Nuggets first quarter to either Jamal or
mpj
two plus threes I don't know if I want
to change it to that in particular
but Ryan you mentioned it
I mentioned it
our friend B Thompson's mentioned it
that first quarter
money line bet
like are we really confident in that
like I I don't let me just review for
everybody what we have so far so we're
all on the same page on what we're
actually debating nuggets first quarter
uh money line the three-way no push
whatever you want to say Brandon Ingram
20 plus points Tatum 30 plus Giannis
over eight and a half rebounds Drew
holiday over 11 and a half points I
don't know but bagel and locks brought
up a good point here and then I'll
address what B Thompson said to us uh to
me specifically
um but B Thompson suggested that we
changed the Nuggets first quarter winner
to either Jamal Murray uh or Michael
Porter Jr two plus threes and then bagel
and lock said that might obliterate the
juice
that is a correct statement because the
having the Nuggets win a quarter but
also a player on the other team
seemingly have a very good game and
score 20 points messes with the parlay
in the way that it's like this it's less
likely to happen that way
um
and then B Thompson said Ryan listen to
me try Tatum 25 plus and Giannis 12 plus
boards I what what are uh B Thompson
he's just said this as a as a nuggets
fan I'm not confident on the first
quarter winner
so that leaves us in the spot that
leaves us in a spot the the Nuggets fan
thing uh lbae I'm a nuggets fan I've hit
on both of them hitting two threes two
out of two times well you've only
brother you've only bet on it twice
that's not a that's not even enough for
a scientific sample size if they put you
in a lab and ask you to do an experiment
that wouldn't even qualify you wouldn't
even be able to write a thesis on that
you need at least three
uh hey Ryan The Vibes that I'm getting
the Vibes that I'm getting is I like the
parlay is just the Denver Nuggets first
quarter one
it has me like huh
I know and guess what dude this guy who
jumped in here and and put you know
alarms around the first quarter money
line has seemingly disappeared I have no
idea where he went he came in here
spammed the chat with it I was like oh
okay you know I'm not gonna be able to
sleep at night tonight if I you know if
we don't bet that and then I ask why and
we're talking about it for the better
part of 20 minutes now and he's not even
here
yeah so I'll I'll leave it up to you
I'll leave it up to you we got the the
audience is in the chat
they're nuggets fans in the chat saying
that they don't know about the pick uh
we did have the guy come in here and and
drop those locks on us
so I'll leave it up to you so you let us
know or should we rock with this nuggets
first quarter money line or should we do
a little
switcheroo
I want to see what Jamal Murray I want
to see what Jamal Murray and Michael
Porter Jr's threes look like and then
we'll and then we'll make a final
decision
Ryan Ryan what
Braden 31 he has a Colorado Avalanche
uh
logo as his profile picture
says nugget spans also don't like the
first quarter money line
I I want to know I think his name is DJ
bands somebody shoot DJ bands a message
and one of two things ask him what the
hell that was about and two ask him to
come back in here and explain himself
because I just don't know how I don't
know how you do that
um I'm trying to look at this okay
Jamal Murray there I mean both of their
lines are are two and a half so we're
we're gonna have to go under and
all right let me ask the chat I'm uh I'm
off the first quarter money line because
this is I yeah I mean just look at the
Braden really Brayden in the comments
really has me nervous about it because
he literally has a Colorado Avalanche
Logo as his profile picture so he's he's
really like a Denver fan like you know
what I mean he's like that so
if he says he's not he's skeptical on
taking it that's going to leave me just
a little skeptical on taking it but I
really think we can go find something
else yeah and people are bringing up a
good point right now Braden and uh a
Rogers saying uh you know we're talking
about what we started off the show with
which is like do we know if yolk's just
playing no so if we bet this now and
then 20 minutes from now joking isn't
playing you know we're cooked we're
cooked that's not happening they're not
going to win the first quarter then
um okay I think Michael Porter Jr so
bagel and locks uh who is our analytics
Guru said uh mpga averages 7.2
three-point attempts per game and three
makes a game so I'm okay if we let's
just play this game a little bit
let's take out the first quarter money
line and we've completely lost any kind
of juice that we potentially had we're
good we're back in here oh okay so if we
did mpga over two and a half threes
I feel better about that
yep I I I like it I like it my man my
man uh Baylin Lots literally broke down
the numbers you just said this I'll just
reiterate it to the people that just
joined the show but if if mpj averages
7.2 three-point attempts and he makes
three a game
he's shooting them
you know what I'm saying he's putting
them up we're gonna get the looks we're
gonna get the looks uh LBA e what are we
we're talking about the threes guy
is in here saying look at the past games
they're making the threes that's what
we're talking about I I don't know like
I don't know I yeah I think this is fine
people watch Jamal Murray like okay if B
Thompson if jokic doesn't play Jamal
getting more than five assists because
he's got that in the last seven
we can't be talking about assists when
we've spent the last five minutes
talking about threes this is this is why
I I walk away from the show and I you
know sometimes I need a drink because
it's like we're jumping from thing to
thing and it's frustrating let's figure
it out
uh Jamal on the other hand 2.6 made
threes on six yeah
I think we're I think we're locking in
Michael Porter Jr I think we have to and
then I think you look at the other game
so Brandon Ingram 20 plus points again
we all agree that that's fine Michael
Porter Jr has regular over two and a
half nothing adjusted Tatum we're going
over his 28 and a half uh points to 30
plus uh Giannis over eight and a half
rebounds which is severely lowering his
rebound total and the same thing with
Drew holiday on 11 and a half points hey
hey Ryan can you do me a favor yes sir
can you go look at mpj's two plus three
pointers mate yeah we're gonna we're
gonna hamper the juice unfortunately you
think so you think we'll go under 400.
yeah yeah it's minus 450. and what we
got it at is minus 136.
um
like you know
to what everyone has been saying what
we're you know what we've been
essentially or what I've been arguing
about with myself I guess is uh
like if yolk if jokic doesn't play those
other guys in the nuggets are gonna have
to step up like and almost beat
Thompson's point about talking about
assists while it drove me crazy and
while I'm upset that he brought it up uh
it almost lends more to what we said
about Michael Porter Jr because if Jamal
Murray's gonna be dishing the ball then
somebody's got to be shooting it and
I'll take Michael Porter Jr all day so
no I yeah that what you said just makes
sense my thing is if jokic does play
does he
no does he does he make three and that's
and that's also the other thing too is
like if but if jokic does play and like
let's say maybe he's not a hundred
percent is it one of those games for
jokic where he's just jogging jogging
around the court
um Scotty boy wants us to drop Tatum to
28. I mean we can I mean we got we got a
little bit of time here
no I I think we're good with that we're
because that's our only plus money play
let's leave it like that you feel
confident he's gonna get 30. I know I
just wanna I do just want to see just in
case
no that's a yep that's gonna be a no
that's gonna be a no for me dog that's
Randy Jackson let me say
um yeah so
yeah all right should we lock it in or
are we still debating no I think I I
like this we're at we're sitting at plus
412 right now
um I think this is
that this is one of the the ones I've
felt good about I this is uh this is a
good one I like this one
um back up to plus 424. this is what
this is what we like to see so okay
shall we Ryan likes it I love it only my
only concern is that Michael Porter Jr
one but I'm going with the Vibes it's
the only thing I can do and and we have
we have bagel and locks with the numbers
I mean Bagel locks comes in here and
doesn't does nothing but drop blocks
um he also said my boy jokic plays like
he's wearing flip-flops when he's hurt
that's a fact that's a fact Giannis
might go for 30 against y'all
yeah I know dude but why why do we why
are we talking about that why are we
talking about it it's in my face it
looks like a lot that's why I was you
know
we're not doing a six leg parlay we
can't ever hit five
we could take out Michael Porter and put
Giannis in there
I don't know I I'm just again seeing a
lot of Trey Murphy again unfortunately
it's too late the Trey Murphy stuff is
gonna haunt me though because a lot of
people came in early with it we went
away from it I asked for it nobody came
in with it we're about to review the
parlay now people are coming in with it
and it's just the whole mess it's a
whole mess and we should have been
quicker you know when we're on the
Pelicans Nuggets game that's when you
drop the Trey Murphy not when I'm about
not what we're about to sign off not
when I'm about to go finish watching the
Mets game not any of that stuff you know
what I mean just don't don't do that
don't do that Brian says don't do that
Ryan
I think we should lock it in
boom okay yeah I'm down uh
read it yeah you don't have to ask I
know I know where you're going okay I
was just making sure just making sure I
know I know
Brandon Ingram 20 plus points Michael
Porter Jr over two and a half made
threes Giannis over eight and a half
rebounds Drew holiday over 11 and a half
points and Jason Tatum 30 plus points
five legs plus four twenty four
tail us on FanDuel and what do we decide
is it this is it this
are we is it Up For Debate
we've never got it
screenshot
we we we never did that before I've been
told it looks like I'm milking a cow
when I go like that I've never milked a
cow before so I couldn't I I couldn't
tell you I'm not a farm boy
unfortunately I'm a city boy uh a suburb
you literally never did that before I'm
sticking to this screenshot I'm just
letting you guys screenshot it when I
when I go and do it on my phone like
that's how I would do it I would squeeze
it yeah but you're you're thinking too
hard bro you're like you're I know
you're in the weeds when I don't need
you in the weeks that's that's true I
mean my again Michael Ritter came in
here and tried to get all technical with
it when it's like we've been going like
this for for the better part of three
months you know yeah whether it makes
sense it's never been up for debate
we've never won that that's what I've
said yeah you're right so we do what we
do that's what up
let's go baby I like those vibes I like
I like this parlay I like this energy
that we got right now because we are
gonna do what we do at the end of the
day so make sure you guys uh
screenshot the parlay over there sitting
at plus 424 because me and my man Ryan
is going to get rich uh Ryan do you have
any last words for the people
um well you know Darren Dion said dude
scored 51 last night you're taking him
for over 11 and a half points in
reference to True holiday
Darren this is why I didn't reach your
place right this is why you don't come
in here with these Vibes you just don't
do it Greg is it Greg is the man who who
turns hate into love I'm the man who
turns hate into silence I will not read
it that's just not what I'm gonna do I'm
not gonna do it I'm looking at these
comments Scotty boy gave us good luck
but he said he can't ride this one we'll
we'll see you at the window dude Scotty
boy also wanted to light the beam Scotty
boy knows Scotty Scotty boys watched the
show before we don't like he knows and
he knows we don't like the beam on this
show but shout out Kings they made the
uh I was just gonna say shout out to the
Sacramento Kings they clinched the
playoffs so they still suck you gotta
Ryan sometimes you sometimes you just
gotta give respect to where respect is
dude I gave them I gave them an
acknowledgment you made the playoffs for
the first time since the Bush
Administration congratulations
you also you also mentioned lighting the
beam and that we don't like the beam
they've been lighting the beam a lot in
Sacramento
just saying
we'll see if they can light the beam
when everyone else thinks it matters
which again is playoffs it's looking
like you know what's looking like they
have a first round matchup if the I
think if the playoffs was the end right
now I'm pretty sure they'll have a first
round match up against the Warriors in
uh
those are going to be home games for the
warriors uh that is true because they
own California and also you know
it's it's Sacramento right I wouldn't I
would like the last I would I would say
they own Northern California they're
still Southern California in in the
Lakers right you know like right again
so we're saying not even not even
Central California to the Sacramento
King Zone
listen you can't the last time
dude I think the last time the last time
they were in the playoffs I think Eminem
was topping the Billboard 100 right like
this is just like it's been a long time
facts no facts it was the uh you know
Missy Elliott was like on the
Billboard's top 100. you feel me exactly
you know back in those days is it worth
it well I mean you know you know yeah
yeah yeah yeah
well it's been a while so actually maybe
maybe I'm forgetting but
I'll tune up on my Missy Elliott just
for the Kings just for the Kings that's
crazy you don't know about Missy what
area here we go here we go let's Get on
Up out here let's Get on Up out of here
all right make sure you guys uh tail our
our our our parlay make sure you guys
tell our parlay uh Ryan we
are out of here
peace
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign